les shihri vendredi nabila a célébré son
anniversaire aux maldives avec thomas
dayer bonne anniversaire dhabi si tout
semblait se dérouler pour le mieux
nabila s'est retrouvé au coeur d'une
très grosse polémique en cause un sac de
luxe que lui offert thomas pour ses 28
ans il s'agit d'un sac très rare qui
coûte près vous avez bien entendu près
de 400000 euros
380 mille euros le sac démenti d'aviron
peut habiter dans un sac
oui mais voilà et c'est une choc
une somme qui a choqué de nombreux
internautes moi je vais donner mon avis
dans un instant là dessus et vous savez
que voilà j'ai toujours dit nabila jeu
vraiment je l'adoré c'est quelqu'un de
foncièrement gentil et voilà c'est
vraiment c'est un amour de fille donc
regarder ça fait une énorme polémique
allant à trouva voilà on peut critiquer
voilà il ya plein de choses vous allez
voir vous avez tous donner votre avis
mais j'ai vu aussi plaints des grilles
les animateurs des animatrices lui
tomber dessus sur sur les réseaux
sociaux
tout ça parce que voilà ils sont un
petit peu jaloux de nabila ça il faut
arrêter aussi regarder en vacances avec
son mari thomas vergara avec lequel elle
vient d'avoir un petit garçon millan
nabil al influence aux rênes de la
téléréalité a décidé de partager avec le
monde l'incroyable cadeau que venait de
lui faire thomas à l'occasion de son
anniversaire un sac de la marque hermès
extrêmement rare appelée himalaya et
dont les quelques exemplaires se serait
écoulé à 380 mille dollars aux enchères
réputé pour être le sac le plus rares au
monde cet objet sertie de diamants et en
peau de crocodile semble avoir comblé la
jeune femme
mais face à ce bonheur une nouvelle
polémique est née sur les réseaux
sociaux de nombreux internautes sont
indignés qu'une célébrité engagé pour la
cause animale puisse faire la promotion
d'un sac en peau de cayman d'autres
internautes ont de leur côté dénoncé
l'argent dépensé dans ce sac certains
s'interrogeant même sur la façon dont
thomas aurait pu payer ce sac lui m
quant à l'animatrice laurence boccolini
elle a également réagi à cette vidéo
parfois je me filme en train de vérifier
s'il a des lcd vache qui rit dans le
frigo sont encore bonnes ensuite paul de
joie je me filme en train de danser une
gigue écossaise ma tartine à la main
parce qu il est 23h45 et qu'elles sont
encore au quai jusqu'à minuit
le monde atteints par ces polémiques
nabila puis thomas vergara ont décidé de
prendre la parole sur les réseaux ccvh
et montanou vous mais vous avez des fous
non mais je suis en intérim depuis
toujours pour un foutu sac à main une
polémique qui rend entaché le séjour du
couple
comme quoi parfois pour vivre heureux
mieux vaut vivre caché alors les chéris
choquer ou pas chaud calendar voir la
réaction de nabila quand elle découvre
le sact lui a offert thomas regarder je
vais regarder moi cette merveille
jusqu'au choix que j'avais fait à risque
j'ai du mal à parler chez désolé on
continue aussi ma vie voilà alors mais
ces lignes racées nabila alors nabil al
a publié une vidéo dans laquelle répond
aux critiques sur le prix de son sac
qu'elle a publiés sur saône appelle des
monts le prix évoqué et règle ses
comptes dès dire ce que vous en pensez
j'ai rien que vous donnez aussi un avis
sur eux voilà laurence boccolini qui l'a
défoncé laurence boccolini dès qu'il ya
un truc façon elle dès qu'elle est là
pour enfoncer les amis nous à chaque
fois que j'ai un truc à elle était là je
reconnais tu as tu sais quoi tu sort la
tête de l'eau à l'arrivée c'est michael
vous savez avec des quêtes pourtant fond
c'est mon frère tu deviens le maillon
faible elle tombée dans l'eau montrèrent
regarde je ne sais pas on vous avez
trouvé ce prix les gars
je sais pas mais vous êtes défaut donc
déjà j'avais même pas en russie avant le
crime cadeaux maintenant je sais ce que
je sais que c'est à ce prix là et en
plus de ça c'est via chez mon cadeau
vous mais vous êtes des fous non mais je
suis en top tweets depuis deux jours
pour un foutu sac à main alors qu'elle
allait aux maldives nabila choqué pas
choquer valérie bénaïm pas choqué non je
suis pas choqué parce que nabila elle a
l'habitude de partager tout avec sa
communauté et sa communauté la suit pas
ce qu'elle a envie de rêver à la halle à
l'histoire de princesse que nous raconte
nabil à son histoire c'est quoi c'est
l'histoire d'une jeune fille qui n'a pas
qu'il ne connaissait pas l'argent qui ne
connaissait pas la belle vie et qui en
s'exposant sur les réseaux sociaux dans
les télé réalités et ses s'est construit
et à gagner son argent elle l'a pas volé
cet argent là après les faits ce qu'elle
veut moi à titre personnel j rep a
dépensé je ne sais pas combien coût de
ce sac mais c'est mais c'est pas mon
problème que je puisse pas moi me l'idée
me l'offrir peu importe
et je préfère cette franchise là qu'une
jeune fille qui me mentir est en écrire
et jouer cause est alors qu'elle n'est
plus cause est donc à l'hmr elle me
raconte quelque chose qui est de l'ordre
de je partage cette histoire qui est une
histoire
alors peut-être pour certains indécente
peut-être pour d'autres achats mais
voilà c'est en habile il ya un autre
truc très choquée je vous le dis voilà
parce que c'est aussi la matière du sac
bb avec la pose de cocody qui est
contraire à ses engagements à nabila je
pense que nabila le savez même pas je
suis même pas sûr qu'elle arrive à la
folie et la péta donc à demander à
nabila de renvoyer le sac
nous savons que nabila se soucie de la
cause animale mais ne s'est certainement
pas que chaque sac en peau de croco est
le produit d'une souffrance atroce et
regardez on veut 2016 la pète avait
réalisé une enquête choc sur l'industrie
des peaux de crocodile qui servent à
fabriquer les sacs et chaussures de luxe
je te montrer des images chocs
regardez et voilà ça aussi ça fait
énormément rire j'ai deux choses le
vietnam exporte environ 30000 peau de
crocodile chaque année dans cette ferme
des milliers de crocodiles étaient
entassés dans
des emplois répugnant de saleté certains
encore plus étroits que la longueur de
leur corps ils sont confinés durant 15
mois dans ces fosses qu'un expert a
désigné comme étant trop restrictives
trop peu stimulantes et inhumaine pour
de grands pros qu'odile dans un autre
élevage des employés électrocute des
crocodiles dans le but de les étourdir
ensuite ils sont transportés dans une
pièce où ils seront abattus alors voilà
donc sa voix la saisie valoir un peu
chocs que je voulais montrer gillard et
je sais que vous adorez david avoue
avait choqué oui je suis choqué à cause
justement vous venez de le montrer de du
sort réservé aux crocodiles sa du prix
un slogan nabil al ghad des fortunes
nabila et thomas ils encore fonctionner
en coupe le cou gagnent des fortunes
on a parlé de deux cachets plus de
100000 euros par mois 3 donc ça me
choque pas pour le prix mais ça me
choque pour la cause animale qu'elle
prétend défendre
à mon avis elle ne devrait pas être
complices de ça donc je lui dis
sincèrement c'est une erreur j'ai aussi
choqué de laurence boccolini alors on va
revenir sur le clash avec laurence
boccolini laurence boccolini
on n'a rien contre elle mais se mêlent
de tout à chaque fois qu'est un truc
laurence vos colis elle vient mettre son
grain de sel
elle a soufflé tout le monde sans
rigoler des cas quelque chose parfois je
me fie rang n'a rien compris à son truc
voilà je vous le dis j'ai rien compris
moi c'est moi son bail est elle donc
nabila lui a répondu très gentiment
nous ne sommes pas de la même génération
j'ai du respect pour les anciens chacun
son époque et ses cols de mépris vous
rentrez l'aide souriez plus tôt et voilà
au début naguila a répondu décidément le
frigo est votre meilleur ami
voilà bon ça c'est laisser les gens
vivre en paix merci avant de supprimer
son message mais ça c'est nabil a
parfois fait des conneries après se
reprend mais c'est vrai que moi lichon
les donneurs de leçons sur les réseaux
sociaux qui dès qu'un truc viennent se
mêler et viennent enfoncer alors que tu
as déjà une polémique de fou ça c'est
insupportable
eric bon d'abord j'en ai marre mme
nabila parce que j'en ai un peu kim
kardashian version discount c'est à dire
que là pas de shampooing faut tourner
mon avis pour être gentil parce que vous
la personne allez-y non mais on lui
offre un sac il faut que la terre
entière l'eau ici ensuite regardé les
vivait avec 25
il est question de toutes ces épreuves
surmontées je me battrai toute ma vie
pour ma famille côté on n'associe pas un
sac à des choses voilà on sait que ça
réussit elle aussi essentielle et
ensuite ce qu'on a vu là sur les
crocodiles je trouve ça ils savent qui
je suis moi ça me soulève le cap non
mais ça fait quand même ça fait quand
même bruit que je trouve non mais je
vous dis mon bien sûr ma vie que j'avais
le sang chaud quand on me demande si je
suis choqué ou pas choquer je suis
choquée à la z
parce qu'il ya beaucoup de gens qui ont
été choquées aussi apprennent on la
connaît donc forcément on sait comment
elle réagit nabila je pense qu'elle est
à la ccl & l est pas dans ces
considérations
j'ai été choqué par le pas le fait que
les gens caste au mans les ans qu'il
avait pas les moyens qui vivait au
prochain me lâche me c'est vraiment
dégueulasse il gagne très bien sa vie
lui aussi en faisant des postes on faut
voir et et me taper dessus en revanche
je suis choquée parce qu'en fait c'est
plus la vérité entre le les postes
promotionnelle commerciaux à la est leur
vraie vie ça je suis sûr qu'ils ont une
réduc changement c'est une raie du son à
une réduction sur le prix du sag hamas
qui à présent faisait la promotion sur
des photos bien bien léché sur une plage
je sais alors qu'elle et ça ça me choque
ça tue ce jeu tu peux facilement
vérifier pour les postes qui sont
rémunérés ou pas où ils allaient
réduction pas parce qu'il ya une loi
pour ça quand tu travailles sur les
socios et que c'est un partenariat km/h
takpara hashtag sponsorisé alors là
c'est pas un partenariat nos classes bah
non c'est bon alors vous êtes amis c'est
parfois trash au québec et non tu sais
pas un très bon on s'en fout là douze
histoires pas choquer kelly non moi je
suis pas choqué pour le prix du sac
passes captées exactement ce qu'elle
veut de son argent
et comme disait valéry à la petite de
montrer toute sa vie donc ça veut
montrer ça c'est un petit peu sa ligne
de conduite donc un garde sa ligne de
conduite
mais par contre je suis choqué pour la
cause animale parce que c'est vrai que
là on voit les vidéos que les sites des
montres mais je suis sûr que nabila qui
va voir la vidéo
mon avis c'était masse après moi moi
raymond pas choquer je suis étonné me
réponds bah non parce que c'est simple
moelleux
nuit thomas moi quand je livrais à
versailles je me disais [ __ ] abidal
edwards derrière ces murs moi je me suis
lavé la quête en taule avec ce mec là à
cause de ces mecs là où pour des
histoires etc ce mec là je me suis ça
tiendra pas leur couple là ça tient il
lui offre un sax comme mes camarades je
suis choquée parce que c'est la cause
animale et elle dit qu'elle et vegan
donc si tu dis que tu es vegan n'accepte
pas ça comme ça et je suis et après
c'est leur argent ils en font ce qu'ils
veulent ce qui est ce qui me dérange
masse et de mettre deux cent mille trois
cent mille euros dans un sac
c'est pour orange et du rouge à lèvres
un portable et des mouchoirs va
t'acheter à chacun fait sa marque
mais chacun fait ce qu'il veut avec son
argent mais j'espère j'espère que ils
garderont leur bonne étoile toute leur
vie et qu'ils auront beaucoup d'argent
toute leur vie qu'on les retrouve pas
dans dans cinq ans dans deux ans nabila
et thomas complètement fauché ses trois
salles chaque fois ces mondiaux diane
bien ducret je suis assez partagé
d'abord mon chéri regarde l'émission et
un pour mon anniversaire on n'était pas
aux maldives il m'a offert un sac à 200
euros et je laime tout autant et le sac
et le shérif surtout ya peut-être c'est
un sac alors c'était pas accepter que
des crocodiles haribo mai mais surtout
je trouve sur évidemment on a besoin les
idoles justement on les adore parce
qu'ils ont ce qu'on peut pas se payer ça
le mécano la mécanique du fantasme secte
mais je trouve qu'il ya beaucoup
d'inutilité et quelle image ça donne en
fait de la réussite se dire j'ai réussi
est ce que c'est vraiment posé dans un
endroit de rêve avec des sacs de luxe
je trouve que c'est un peu réducteur et
peut-être un tout petit peu matérialiste
sans que cela me choque pour autant la
fille est très belle la photo est belle
la plage aussi un sac aussi un peu moi
je suis avec vous oui mais où qui série
à ceux comme moi je me souviens j'adore
nabila et je lui conserve toute mon
affection
sauf que je me souviens que quand elle
était ici je trouve ça un peu triste
qu'elle soit désormais que dans le
placement de produit que dans la façon
de montrer jeu tout qu'elle vaut mieux
que ça quand elle était ici sous une
albanie mais à quai sur amazon
quand elle est ici vous l'avait obligé à
bosser et comme par hasard elle s'est
rendu compte que ça ne sont pas voulu
obliger à bosser salah passionnel beauce
boon avait là qu'elle fait elle le fait
très très bien répond son instinct c'est
un exemple je vous dis ça fait bizarre
de masque parce que vous ne m'en suis
jamais réjoui isabelle pasquet isabelle
vous n'êtes pas de la même génération
mais isabelle mais je vous dis pas parce
que non mais juste et beau souffler
parce qu'elle fait nabil
à ce qu'elle fait là des lacets un
travail et ce qu'elle fait elle le fait
très bien je la gestion de son instinct
de son image tout ça s'est extrêmement
bien travaillé donc elle travaille donc
vous ne le voyez pas trash de ce que tu
vas côté mais rien à voir
[Musique]
ça c'est des paroles mais non sportives
aussi c'est parce qu'elles disent non
mais cette annexion pensait boccolini
qui lui a mis dans la gueule mais ça
c'est ça c'est à bala à lyon avec les
loups elle fait toujours ça dès qu'un
mec a enfoncé le fait mais moi je trouve
à oui c'est vrai moi ce qui me saoule
avec avec une habile mais c'est balla
balla pour elle pour les footeux guitare
dès qu'un mec qui réussit des carmes et
qui est un peu honnête son commerce est
sale abidal vient à elle vient de nulle
part
elle a réussi c'est un rêve et c'est
magique pourquoi pas toujours chier sur
les gens ce qu'ils pensent qu'ils ont
juste l'envié de montrer leur bonheur
alors oui le seul le sac qui coûte une
fortune
effectivement ça crocodile et ça fait
chier d'accord si vous n'êtes pas ça
mérite pas de nulle part tu balances pas
300000 euros quand même et ça te dérange
pas ça me dérange pas bouder question ça
me dérange pas alors ces histoires
dernière
[Rires]
allez voilà alors voilà en tout cas
voilà on va voir ce qu'on pensait
téléspectateurs tiens ça je serais
choqué ses plaies ses 55 ans et envoyer
ses 55 ans qu'elle s'est fait défoncer
et moi je demande vraiment à laurence
boccolini on n'a rien contre l areq
laurence de te mêler de tout les doigts
parce que c'est devenu insupportable
quoi voilà fais ton travail
voilà je suis pas jouer ta ferme effet
le ya aussi une notion d'investissement
aussi beaucoup ont parlé ça veut dire
que tu achètes 1,5 à ce prix là et tu le
revends beau c'est comme dans le site en
une oeuvre d'art il ya beaucoup de gens
qui accordent et d'art et ben ça fait
désordre d'arômes ou la cause animale or
si en plus c'est une spéculation à la
cause animale c'est vrai que ça doit
s'asseoir ici